so Sarah Huckabee Sanders was refused
service at a restaurant you may heard
about it it was a mean thing to do but
in the new era where Mean Girls rule
some Mean Girls think it's a plus
Washington Post's Jennifer Rubin wrote a
piece on the lost art of shunning in
which she feels for the restaurant owner
but Jennifer's shunning 'he's not a lost
art it was once used to ostracize people
for religious reasons its extremism but
Jennifer hates Trump and everyone linked
to him so maybe extremism is warranted
right meanwhile Maxine Waters wants more
than just shunning you are not welcome
at this gasoline station so where will
this end well we saw how it started if
you vote for Trump then you the voter
view not donald trump or standing at the
bar border like nazis going you hear you
hear and i think we now have to flip it
and it's a given the evilness of donald
trump but if you vote you can no longer
separate yourself what a dope why is the
guy yelling nazi often best at imitating
one
he just branded millions of people which
opens doors to anything and shunning is
the least of it harassment name-calling
violence or coming right to your home to
terrify your family
[Applause]
so what if shunning went both ways
what if cops ignored 9-1-1 calls because
of politics who do you think the police
supports more anyway Nancy Pelosi or
Donald Trump it's an easy guess but the
police would never ever do that because
they know what it means to serve the
public
what's as bad as shunning how about
desiring a person's presence only as
hired help
when pondering this new tribalism among
restaurants leftist matthew Yglesias
snart hmm who is going to cook at
Republican only restaurants Thank You
Maddie now we know the real reason
liberals love Mexicans and Hondurans
they expect them to vote their way but
only after their shifts over in the
kitchen all right Dina should Maxine
walk it back I have a feeling she's not
gonna walk it back I don't think she's
going to but Nancy Pelosi tried to write
she tweeted that that's unacceptable and
that she wants to make America beautiful
again and she did take a moment to say
like this is that people are reacting to
something meaning Trump but she was not
for the instability but in Maxine Waters
certainly not there it's because
everything is national news now yeah
Maxine Waters years ago in her district
it wouldn't have been front-page news
everywhere but now you do run the risk
that somebody like Maxine Waters paints
everybody in the Democratic Party with a
broad brush but what she's discussing is
something super unhealthy it is
obnoxious and what I'm concerned about
is for people who think this is good
what happens then if somebody feels
cornered like we're we are creatures
that want to survive right you're
cornered you will fight back right and
this could escalate very quickly yeah
you know what I'm torn about the
restaurant thing because I am a
libertarian and I feel like you should
if you don't want somebody at your
restaurant is that more of an accepted
practice because that stance is no
longer tethered to causing hardship it's
like it's not like that it's not like
the 60s so if I say you can't come in
here that might be the only restaurant
in town so is this more acceptable
acceptable because it's not as
hard to find another place to go do you
follow me no I didn't but I'm trying so
they write what I think what were you
suggesting like in the 60s was over race
yeah well and also it created a real
hardship but these days she could go to
another restaurant I'm just wondering Oh
for a black person in the 60s maybe
there was another restaurant Bob yeah
that's my point
currently they were black restaurants
you could go to so but that's a that's a
different story in the sense that
there's a tremendous and sad history in
terms of race and exclusion I don't
think you know even President Trump
wouldn't say there's any history of
Trump supporters being excluded from
restaurant yeah I get know what I'm
saying is is it okay now because there
are so many other options in general for
people that if you say I don't want you
my restaurant you can go somewhere else
that's my point I make you know I don't
think it was the right thing to do and I
guess I would pick up on Dana said I
think Nancy Pelosi said at the
Washington Post said it editorial board
David Axelrod who was Obama's chief
political strategist said the same thing
Axelrod put it in these terms he said
you know Trump has really been rough
in terms of his lease of language and a
lot of the kind of things he's
encouraged his supporters to do but it's
not a reason it doesn't justify then
being a lack of civility or rudeness to
people who you have a different point of
agreement a point of disagreement with
that it will just lead us all down the
road to Hell here where you it it's we
reduce ourselves to tribalism and we're
shouting and screaming at each other and
breaking apart our common bonds as
Americans I just don't think it's good
yeah you're speaking of tribalism in
Trump Jesse I do think there's a
difference between Trump and this in the
sense that his his what whatever you
call that thing he did was debt was
directed at other Republicans for the
longest time it wasn't an ideological of
ideological origin right yes I don't see
the similarity with the restaurant thing
and like you said you're a libertarian
so maybe it's illegal to you know ban
someone you don't like from the
restaurant doesn't make it right yeah
but I think this behavior just plays
into Donald Trump's hands remember the
last you know couple years under the
Obama administration you had an Tifa you
had racial riots you had open borders
chaos even before you had Occupy Wall
Street
President Trump was elected to clean up
that kind of mess and the American
people fundamentally are decent people
they want other people to be respected
and they're not going to tolerate kind
of rageaholics disrupting law-abiding
Americans from having dinner and I
believe it starts with the left and the
media's demonization of Republicans if
you spend a year and a half saying
Donald Trump his cabinet and the 60
million Americans who voted for him are
Nazis
that is going to incite people to treat
people like Nazis and yell at them and
harass them and put their lives at
danger and the Nazi comparison is lazy
historically inaccurate and it means
they've lost the argument so I believe
that's happening because the Trump is
winning not losing and this is driving
the left crazy
he's securing the borders and that is a
threat to the left they can't handle it
they're not acting like they're going to
win in November they're frantic and
they're acting like they're desperate
because this is all they have left and
if he succeeds and he is reelected they
have nothing so you have the people like
Peter Fonda you have Maxine Waters Kathy
Griffin they are literally melting down
before our eyes and there's no one in
the Democratic Party that can control
them and it's just helping Donald Trump
succeed and his numbers are at record
high right now
hey you know Kimberly Charles
Krauthammer just passed away he he maybe
he had a phrase that we all remember
which was as a conservative we think
they are wrong but the left thinks were
evil yeah and I think was this is the
problem is that if they think that
you're evil they can do anything to you
if they think you're a Nazi then morally
they are right to go after you right it
justifies the level of vitriol and you
know the the rhetoric that is just so
you know repugnant to attack people or
someone's family to be able to say to
somebody you can't eat here at this
restaurant yet they fight for the cases
for even like say gay rights to be able
to have a wedding cake made or something
of that nature there's a real you know
hypocrisy latent in there but if they
feel justified like with the anti-shah
and others that say well we're fighting
against evil against something like the
devil then
they say they're justified in doing it
morally and ethically so therefore
anything goes like somebody like Maxine
Waters calling for this or calling to
put you know a child in a cage with
pedophiles making personal attacks
against families or increasing sort of
the level of rhetoric and hate to say go
after them personally I mean can you
imagine Sarah Sanders or their family
going into a restaurant and you can tell
somebody you can't eat there I mean this
is so far like going back you know in
time this isn't moving forward in terms
of civility of discourse and disagreeing
with somebody versus you know hating
their guts and saying I can do anything
to you
whether it's rhetoric or whether it's
physical violence to justify my cause
because of you know who you are and what
you stand for
I don't think let me just say I don't
think this started before I think the
lot of this is out of Trump's rhetoric
and the way that Trump speaks and Trump
policies and so I didn't see this
happening under Obama I don't remember
this happening under even when there was
anger ever at george w bush about not
finding weapons of mass destruction and
crude things about blood for it but it I
don't remember this kind of acting out
on either side but what you have now is
I think people focusing on this and not
on the policy and a lot of people my
fact most Americans don't like
separating children from parents and
that's what all those they could have
solved that problem but crying Chuck
Schumer refused to act in the Senate and
roaming about it and waited until it
became button issued for to hurt
President Trump I don't think it's fair
to criticize Donald Trump for people
treating the people that work for him
like animals that's not right he's
reading the people that work for him
when people protest Sarah Huckabee
Sanders you can't blame that on Donald
Trump which you just did I think that's
unfair and that's on them that is not a
view if you go to a Donald Trump rally
and you and Donald Trump is standing up
there and saying I'll pay legal fees if
any of you want to beat up some of these
people mean what is going on we all know
now that the people swinging were paid
oh if you if if Hillary Clinton is
elected and points a Supreme Court judge
who does anything to your gun rights
well I guess you second men people have
to take I mean come on
hasn't been examples of violent and hate
the Trump supporters range disrespecting
people in public places like restaurants
like is happening on the other side what
do you call that lady getting run over a
year ago in Charlottesville Jesse I
think that wouldn't blame Donald Trump
the problem is how do you blame the
restaurant owner nobody in the
Democratic Party told the restaurant
don't know what to do the people on the
Democratic Party have been calling Trump
a Nazi and saying and like Maxine Waters
saying right I encourage you to go call
people out to their face and refuse them
service I think I think we can I think I
think that what about ISM a thing can go
on forever you could go from
Charlottesville you can go back to
Scalise Gabby Giffords you can go back
to protesters calling Vietnam vets baby
killers you can go as far back as that
it doesn't I mean it it doesn't help